visiter une usine ou un atelier pendant
les vacances
près d'un million de français ont tenté
l'expérience en 2017 locaux ou étrangers
ces touristes sont à la recherche
d'authenticité de savoir faire et de
métier une autre manière de parcourir la
région
l'occasion aussi de mieux connaître les
produits fabriqués à côté de chez soi on
va vous expliquer en fait comment on
transforme la fève au chocolat donc en
passant par les trois métiers différents
ateliers cuisine chez max bauchet et
petit rappel du processus de fabrication
du chocolat avant de mettre la main à la
pâte
c'est vrai que j'avais envie aussi de
savoir comment on pouvait notamment
relevé faire fondre le chocolat j'avais
je m'étais renseigné je sais qu'il ya
des techniques particulières donc
j'avais envie en fait de pratiquer les
techniques et va le mieux c'est quand
même d'aller sur place chez un
chocolatier plutôt que de consommer
bêtement on comprend quand même mieux
comment ça se passe créé en 2013 les
ateliers cuisine rencontre un certain
succès chez max vaucher ouvrir au public
c'est une seconde nature
dès son installation à blois en 1986 le
chocolatier décide de travailler en
vitrine dans sa boutique
j'ai été décriée au départ ce qu'on m'a
dit mais surtout surtout faut partir ça
parce que tu vas faire voir des secrets
tu vas faire là le chocolat c'est sale
c'est vrai que généralement son nez sur
le tablier
alors j'étais décrié puis finalement
belgique moi je suis le contraire
je vais faire voir ce qu'on sait faire
ça me permettait de sortir des labos ça
me permettait de sortir de des sous-sols
bien souvent le travail en sous sol où
derrière les boutiques
ben non moi je voulais faire voir ce
qu'on fait des jeux voulait exister
quelque part aussi pour rester attractif
il déménage sa filière production en
2005 à bracieux a fait construire un
laboratoire tout neuf et le compléter
avec un véritable parcours de visite
alors là on se retrouve en bas une
plantation une plantation qui s'étaient
eux soit dans des pays d'afrique ou en
amérique du sud
voilà non gérés constituer un petit peu
cette plantation pour expliquer aux gens
le travail des planteurs que c'est très
très important
faut vraiment faire découvrir d'autres
le cacaoyer et puis aussi le travail de
la fermentation du séchage voilà donc
les gens se retrouvent un petit peu dans
une ambiance chaude et à la fois un
petit peu tropicale quoi bon jour le
slam de la cabosse à la tablette
le parcours pédagogique mène tout droit
à la boutique 75% du chiffre d'affaires
de l'entreprise vient directement de ces
visites touristiques et cela grâce à une
situation géographique plutôt attractive
et touristes ils vont avant tout à
chambord qui après demande et ils vont
se balader en soi ni fond de château ils
font cheverny ils font aussi bien sur
ovale il pas cela à un moment donné ils
ont été un petit déclic en disant tiens
on va changer on va les voir la
chocolaterie on est attirés
certains entrepreneurs ouvre facilement
leurs portes d'autres tentent
l'expérience depuis peu à orval dans le
cher une vo ufo a décidé d'ouvrir ses
locaux au grand public depuis quatre ans
bienvenue à une vo et fo anciennement
les ateliers dorval on a changé de nom
le 1er janvier 2018 donc peut-être que
là tout est normal parle un petit peu
mieux pour certaines personnes voilà
donc on fait la construction et à la
fabrication de wagons industrielle pour
le fret
bref présentation de l'entreprise avant
d'accompagner sur le site
la quinzaine de touristes présents ce
jour là l'équipement de sécurité est
obligatoire avant d'observer le gros
oeuvre passage obligé par le bureau
d'études
on va avoir une petite centaine
d'assemblées de gros assemblage et
petits sous assemblages et on peut avoir
500 ou 600 pièces primaires voire pour
un wallon donc ça fait quand même
beaucoup de trucs à gérer on va
commencer par la fabrication
donc c'est david le responsable équipe
du matin de la fabrication qui va vous
expliquer un petit peu plus technique
ce qu'ils font dans les ateliers
implanté depuis un siècle à orval ça
c'est le principe du montage
l'entreprise fabrique rénove et
entretien des wagons de transport de
marchandises les pièces sont importés
puis assemblés dans ces hangars et voilà
ça donne un assemblage de wagons en fait
on se fait une fois que c'est tout a
semblé on le passe à côté au frein aux
systèmes de freins 75 ouvriers
spécialisés en chaudronnerie soudure ou
dégazages qui travaillent sur le site
ici les salariés sortent en moyenne un
wagon par jour et celle du tourisme
industriel
ailleurs aussi mais a fortiori en local
c'est important de connaître ces
entreprises que souvent elles sont pas
très connues elles sont connus dans leur
domaine mais comme c'est des domaines
très variés
il ya souvent des pépites sur le tissu
économique local con qu'on côtoie et
qu'on connaît pas quoi donc c'est encore
plus intéressant de savoir comment ça
marche si c'est à côté on découvre
toujours des savoir-faire des
spécificités de pleins d'astuces voilà
les les produits n'arrivent pas tous
fait les magasins quoi il s'est bien
passé des choses en amont et c'est
intéressant de comprendre ce qui se
passe les annuler
c'est sa cécité manuellement donc il ya
un gars testerine échelle
on a fait il est en
les terminaux comme ça permet comme sur
elle-même et 30 minutes a pas besoin
le run c'est dur quand vous avez fait la
longueur
pour cette entreprise ces visites
publiques sont une vitrine pour faire
découvrir l'ensemble des métiers manuels
une autre manière de recruter dans un
secteur qui souffre d'un manque de main
d'oeuvre
c'est difficile aujourd'hui de trouver
des gens pour faire ce travail de
soudure de chaudronnerie de maintenance
et je me suis dit qu en ouvrant les
portes une chance sur mille
mais une chance et une chance et on peut
parfois provoquer susciter de l'intérêt
et trouver des gens qui finalement on
dire bah tiens il ya une usine c'est ça
que j'aime c'est ça que je voulais faire
certains touristes ne sont pas là par
hasard
ils viennent pour affiner leur
orientation professionnelle pour savoir
si j'ai fait un bon choix et qu'ils ont
décidé par la prochaine jetant j'ai pas
trop l'idée du coup genre pour voir au
moins ce qui me plaît ce que le poivre
on nous dira si je veux aller dans la
filière gros reste dans général depuis
2014 et leur ouverture au public les
ateliers dorval accueille aussi des
apprentis compagnons un besoin de
publicité pour faire connaître le
savoir-faire des équipes forcément fier
de leur production bien souvent il ya
des gens ils voyent un wagon sur arraï
ils savent pas ce que c'est voilà un bon
quand on voit comment le cos on le
conçoit de a à z ça arrive par un bogie
un châssis on assemble c'est toujours
intéressant de savoir c'est comme un
wagon de voyageurs au déroulement dedans
ça soit là quand on sait comment c'est
conçu ces différentes
du wagon autres acteurs à lignières la
société a grip est la dernière
entreprise française de construction de
tracteurs forestiers patricia pérochon a
repris la société alors en grande
difficulté elle s'est inscrite cette
année au programme de visites
d'entreprises géré par l' agence de
développement touristique du cher
comment s'est passé votre votre visite
alors très très bien je suis très
contente d'avoir ouvert les portes de
l'usiné
parce que en fait je pensais pas que ça
m'apporterait autant aussi d'accord
parce que c'était très riche humainement
il ya eu des questions pertinentes et
j'ai été très flatté que les gens soient
aussi intéressé sur cette histoire
réaliser un bilan de la première visite
est aussi important que de la préparer à
berry provence non seulement les agents
recrute de nouvelles entreprises
mais il prodigue certains conseils on
fait toujours un repérage avant les
visites on parle un petit peu justement
avec la responsable de l'entreprise et
puis on voit comment on peut articuler
cette visite
alors après il faut parler évidemment
historique mais aussi de l'activité
qu'est ce qui a motivé aussi le fait de
vouloir ouvrir l'entreprise
donc il ya beaucoup de choses
effectivement qu'ils sont qui sont
faites avant cette visite un besoin de
publicité pour une entreprise centenaire
qui a failli disparaître
on était plus que six en 2014 reprendre
un projet industriel à 6 ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie et j'ai vraiment un
coeur de de fédérer des bonnes personnes
en fin dé la bienveillance pour que ça
puisse perdurer quoi parce que on ne
s'est pas battue autant pour que ça
s'arrête demain donc tout passe par la
médiatisation tout passe par le contact
puis voilà
j'ai dans l'idée de faire beaucoup mieux
les années après parce qu'on voit
évoluer l'entreprise a évolué et voilà
et on va ouvrir les portes un peu plus
parce que je pense qu'il ya une attente
même au niveau du personnel de d'être
reconnu surtout avec l'opération l'été
des entreprises aujourd'hui baptisée
visite secrète l'indre et le cher sont
les seuls départements à organiser et
centralisée ce type de visite avec un
but bien précis faire la promotion de
tout ce qui peut exister en dehors
justement de ski et visites
patrimoniales
donc effectivement on a des sites
touristiques mais on a aussi des visites
qui sont autres alors l'industrie ou vos
repas le reste de l'année donc
l'intéresse c'est découvrir l'envers du
décor de toutes ces entreprises qui
existent dans le département
le tourisme d'entreprise une affaire qui
marche depuis 11 ans en berry concernant
l'accès sur le site gens vous rappeler
qu'on est sur un site industriel qui
plaisait nucléaire donc vous me suivez
moi vous restez entre lui et moi sur les
passages piétons sur les zones piétonnes
et tout se passera bien pousser pour
salles de conférences je vous ai demandé
si vous n'avez pas passé de contrôle de
médecine nucléaire type scintigraphique
un jour au préalable avant la visite
si c'était le cas vous êtes rentré sur
le site ne pourrait pas se faire donc on
va vérifier que vous n'êtes
radiologiquement propre en passant ces
portiques sécurité maximale pour entrer
dans la centrale nucléaire
les touristes sont impatients ils
viennent de passer une heure à revoir le
fonctionnement de la fission nucléaire
sassus mon programme de première es ce
que j'ai fait cette année avec toute la
fission nucléaire et où donc franchement
c'est que du bon pour moi le groupe n'a
pas accès au réacteur
il passe en salle des machines un
immense bâtiment où se trouve condenseur
turbines et alternateurs géant l'endroit
où l'électricité est produite
allez-y voilà encore un portique avant
de se rendre au simulateur
historiquement en france il y avait
trois simulateurs répartis sur les sites
et il y avait un besoin croissant en
formation pour les personnels edf
donc il a été décidé de construire un
simulateur par site l'entreprise fait
appel à une société prestataire pour
réaliser les visites touristiques 5000
touristes sont passés par belleville sur
loire l'année dernière edf ouvre les
portes de ses sites de production depuis
trente ans un besoin de communication un
besoin de transparence surtout en fait
on n'a aucune question taboue toutes les
questions que posent les visiteurs on y
répond effectivement on a travaillé
l'amélioration de la présentation
poitiers d'être plus pédagogue parce
qu'effectivement notre industrie peut
être perçue parfois comme complexe donc
il a fallu faire preuve de pédagogie on
a amélioré l'accès ce qu'il faut que les
gens comprennent c'est que le meilleur
allié du renouvelable et nucléaire parce
qu'il faut compenser les moments où le
renouvelable ne va pas produire et
quitte à le faire le faire par des
moyens décarbonée à l'heure du nouveau
mix énergétique où la part du nucléaire
dans la production doit réduire la
communication et stratégiques
même avec les plus réticents on a un peu
de génération
on a connu charneau me et compagnie et
c'est vrai que l'image des cheminées
avec le panache de fumée qui sortent
s'était pas toujours très rassurant
en fait on s'aperçoit que c'est très
sécurisé edf aujourd'hui c'est le
nucléaire c'est 86 % de la production
delek et que pour en sortir enfin je
vois pas trop les éoliennes et
les barrages faire 90 % d'électricité
donc pour l'instant je pense qu'on a on
est obligé de rester dans le nucléaire
comprendre apprendre observer des
métiers le tourisme d'entreprise permet
de voir les coulisses de sites souvent
confidentielles en découvrant le
patrimoine industriel local le visiteur
découvre sous un angle nouveau notre
région
un voyage dans le made in france dans le
médine centre val de loire